[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing some
popular fan theories pertaining to none
other than hermione granger i'm going to
discuss five theories in total starting
with the worst and working towards the
best i'll be kicking things off with a
completely terrible theory and
progressively working my way towards
what i feel is the best one if you
enjoyed this type of video let me know
by liking the video and leaving a
comment i've got five more hermione
theories ready to go and i can also do
it for other characters anyway let's get
started
5. hermione is harry's sister yes we
heard that correctly this popular harry
potter fan theory suggests that the boy
who lived harry potter is in fact
related to hermione gene granger
i think we can blame george lucas and
the relation between luke and leia for
this one this is a messed up theory for
many reasons and it's completely logical
but let me entertain you with just a few
of the main arguments for why and how
these two may be related the original
theorist kicks things off by pointing
out that hermione's behavior with harry
is very sister-like and that there is
something unique about their friendship
in an unromantic way this point seems
far too vague and provides zero evidence
that the pair are related having a
feeling that there is something unique
about a relationship isn't supporting
evidence for a theory the next point
made is that hermione knew a lot about
harry before arriving at hogwarts
again this piece of evidence isn't
really significant at all
harry was famous his name was everywhere
and to my name is the type of person to
read up on things
of course she knew about harry everyone
did
next the point is made that jk rowling
has a tendency to describe physical
resemblances between relatives in harry
potter but that hermione was never
described as resembling her family
this is one of the weakest arguments for
this theory so far
there are many other arguments more or
less on the same level as the ones noted
above that support i use that very
loosely here this theory
however it seems as though the main
supporting claim this theory boasts is
that lily and james may have had a
secret child that they put up for
adoption
hermione
this is one of the worst theories i've
heard particularly as jk rowling has
admitted that she felt as though harry
and hermione should have ended up
together
4. hermione was homeless in the trio's
last few years of school the threat that
was voldemort in the death eaters seemed
to be getting nearer and nearer closer
to home each and every day
the wizarding world was on edge and
people were beginning to prepare for the
worst a fully fledged return of
voldemort and a takeover of the
wizarding world however voldemort's
return didn't just mean bad news for the
wizarding community it also unbeknownst
to them posed a significant threat to
muggles and the muggle world
queue hermione and her parents
knowing that the danger would eventually
stretch beyond the confines of the
wizarding world hermione granger knew
that she would have to make a difficult
choice
she would have to decide whether or not
she would wipe her parents memories
given that hermione was a prominent
figure in the fight against voldemort it
made her a target and by extension her
parents
this prompted her to take action with
hermione eventually erasing her parents
memories
after wiping their memories hermione
didn't return home until the threat that
was voldemort had been eliminated which
meant that close to a year went by
before she eventually returned home
she was homeless one dark potter theory
suggested hermione was actually homeless
for a lot longer than one year
wiping her parents memories several
years before 1997.
this theory is supported by the fact
that hermione was always with either
harry or ron during vacations
she spent her entire summers at either
grimmeld place or the borough
not spending any time with her parents
at all
after seeing writing on the wall that
voldemort was coming back hermione
freaked out and hoping to keep our
parents as safe as possible wiped their
memories years before we had previously
thought
hermione is a smart girl so acting in
advance like this does make sense
but i'm not sure i totally buy it
3. hermione's academic excellence
now it should come as no surprise when i
tell you that hermione is highly
intelligent in fact in one of my videos
where i rank the 10 most intelligent
characters i put hermione at number two
while studying hermione granger was one
of the most talented witches of her
entire year
and the entire school for that matter
in fact hermione may have been one of
the most studious and brightest witches
to have ever graced hogwarts she began
attending hogwarts at the same time as
harry ron and given her affinity for
learning and knowledge it's no surprise
that she became a talented witch
she had a thirst for knowledge and
through her dangerous adventures with
harry and ron became ready for anything
and everything that came her way she was
well-rounded competent and a quick
thinker able to think critically under
all kinds of pressure not only was she
studious she was just naturally very
intelligent things came easily to her
and her inquisitive nature only meant
that she stockpiled all manners of
information
okay so hermione is smart what's the
theory the theory in question suggests
that hermione's excellence can be
attributed to the addition of her muggle
education prior to attending hogwarts
in one of my older videos i discussed
all of the subjects taught at hogwarts
21 to be exact and one thing that you
may or may not know is that many basic
foundational skills taught in muggle
school are excluded hermione however
went to muggle school and learned these
excluded topics prior to her attending
hogwarts
yes some other students received a
muggle education as well
but the theory boasts that hermione's
innate intelligence paired with rich
foundational knowledge of core subjects
gave her the edge needed to become the
brightest witch of her age compare that
to ron who can't spell for toffee and
this totally reasonable theory
completely checks out
2. hermione's true bloodline
as far as we know hermione granger was a
muggle-born witch born in 1979 to
michael parents mr and mrs granger
according to canon hermione didn't
realize that she was in fact a witch
until she received her hogwarts letter
at the age of 11. furthermore hermione
was the first magical person in her
family and went on to have two
half-blood children with ron weasley
blood status is one of the most
controversial aspects of the wizarding
world a concept in which wizarding
families can be distinguished by the
level of magically endowed family
members
generally speaking people are
slaughtered into one of the following
categories pureblood half blood or
muggle with the special term muggleborn
referring to a witch or wizard with two
non-magical parents hermione is a muggle
through and through
this theory however is about to bust
that wide open
in the sixth harry potter professor
horace loghorn asks hermione if she is
related to a certain hector dagworth
granger to which she responds that she
doesn't think so because she is a
muggleborn
so who was hector dagworth granger why a
wizard of course a british one that
founded the most extraordinary society
of potioneers this leaves one big
question is it just a coincidence that
he shared a name with hermione is it
impossible for them to be related the
theory in question suggested hector was
one of hermione's ancestors and that
there have been a long line of squibs
non-magical wizards born to at least one
magical parent in the granger family
tree
this would explain hermione's parents
visiting diagon alley and might also
explain the connection to hector
dagworth granger
an intellectually impressive ancestor
does seem about right for hermione this
one's a bit of a stretch but the theory
is sound and i do quite enjoy it
1. hermione's time crunch before we get
into this one let me explain time
turners
time turners are magical devices
manufactured by the department of
mysteries used for time travel
a typical time turner is operated by
turning an hourglass which directly
corresponds to the number of hours that
you can travel back in time
traditional time turners are limited and
that you are only able to travel back a
maximum of five hours in the 1993 school
year mcgonagall gifts the time turner to
hermione so that she's able to attend
additional classes
hermione's immense workload finally
seemed to be getting to her every night
without fail hermione was to be seen in
the corner of the common room several
tables spread with books arithmancy
charts rune dictionaries diagrams of
muggles lifting heavy objects and file
upon file of extensive notes she barely
spoke to anybody and snapped when she
was interrupted but did mcgonagall
really gift hermione the time turner or
was it acquired another way
this theory challenges that
though not particularly developed this
theory is quite an interesting one and
entirely plausible at that
it's a guess that rather than being
given a time turner by mcgonagall
hermione stole the time turner from the
department of mysteries with
dumbledore's help
the main support behind this theory is
that in the order of the phoenix when
the trio visit the department of
mysteries hermane seemed to already know
certain things about the department
things that would require being there
before this might also better explain
why a student was entrusted with a
temporal manipulation device
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think had you heard of these
theories before do you want five more of
these on hermione another character
leave a comment down below and don't
forget to like subscribe to support
future content until next time remember
awful things happen to wizards who've
meddled with time
[Music]